everybody feels lonely from time to time
when we have no one to sit next to at
lunch when we moved to a new city or
when nobody has time for us at the
weekend but over the last few decades
this occasional feeling has become
chronic for millions in the UK 60% of 18
to 34 year olds say they often feel
lonely in the u.s. 46% of the entire
population feel lonely regularly we are
living in the most connected time in
human history
and yet an unprecedented number of us
feel isolated being lonely and being
alone are not the same thing you can be
filled with bliss by yourself and hate
every second surrounded by friends
lowliness is a purely subjective
individual experience if you feel lonely
you are lonely a common stereotype is
that loneliness only happens to people
who don't know how to talk to people or
how to behave around others but
population-based studies have shown that
social skills make practically no
difference for adults when it comes to
social connections loneliness can affect
everybody money fame power beauty social
skills are great personality nothing can
protect you against loneliness because
it's part of your biology
loneliness is a bodily function like
hunger hunger makes you pay attention to
your physical needs loneliness makes you
pay attention to your social needs your
body cares about your social needs
because millions of years ago it was a
great indicator of how likely you were
to survive
natural selection rewarded our ancestors
for collaboration and for forming
connections with each other our brains
grew and became more and more fine-tuned
to recognize what others thought and
felt and to form and sustain social
bonds being social became part of our
biology you were born into groups of 50
to 150 people which you usually stayed
with for the rest of your life getting
enough calories staying safe and warm or
caring for offspring was practically
impossible alone being together meant
survival being alone meant death so it
was crucial that you got along with
others for your ancestors the most
dangerous threat to survival was not
being eaten by line but not getting the
social vibe of your group and being
excluded to avoid that your body came up
with social pain pain of this kind is an
evolutionary adaptation to rejection a
sort of early warning system to make
sure you stop behavior that would
isolate you your ancestors who
experienced rejection as more painful
were more likely to change their
behavior when they got rejected and thus
stayed in the tribe while those who did
not got kicked out and most likely died
that's why rejections hurt and even more
so why loneliness is so painful these
mechanisms for keeping us connected
worked great for most of our history
until humans began building a new world
for themselves the loneliness epidemic
we see today radio knee started in the
late Renaissance Western culture began
to focus on the individual intellectuals
moved away from the collectivism of the
Middle Ages while the young Protestant
theology stressed individual
responsibility
this trend accelerated during the
Industrial Revolution people left their
villages and fields to enter factories
communities that had existed for
hundreds of years began to dissolve
while cities grew as our world rapidly
became modern this trend sped up more
and more today we move vast distances
for new jobs love and education and
leave our social net behind we meet
fewer people in person and we meet them
less often than in the past
in the u.s. the mean number of close
friends dropped from 3 in 1985 to 2 in
2011 most people stumble into chronic
loneliness by accident you reach
adulthood and become busy with work
university romance kids and Netflix
there's just not enough time the most
convenient and easy thing to sacrifice
is time with friends until you wake up
one day and realize that you feel
isolated that you yearn for close
relationships but it's hard to find
close connections as adults and so
loneliness can become chronic while
humans feel pretty great about things
like iPhones and spaceships our bodies
and minds are fundamentally the same
they were 50,000 years ago
we are still or biologically fine-tuned
to being with each other
large scale studies have shown that the
stress that comes from chronic
loneliness is among the most unhealthy
things we can experience as humans it
makes you age quicker
it makes cancer Divya Alzheimer's
advance faster your immune systems
weaker loneliness is twice as deadly as
obesity and as deadly as smoking a pack
of cigarettes a day
the most dangerous thing about it is
that once it becomes chronic it can
become self sustaining physical and
social pain use common mechanisms in
your brain both feel like a threat and
so social pain leads to immediate and
defensive behaviour when it's inflicted
on you when Logan s becomes chronic your
brain goes into self-preservation mode
it starts to see danger and hostility
everywhere but that's not all
some studies found that when you're
lonely your brain is much more receptive
and alert to social signals while at the
same time it gets worse at interpreting
them correctly you pay more attention to
others but you understand them less the
part of your brain that recognizes faces
gets out of tune and becomes more likely
to categorize neutral faces as hostile
which makes it distrustful of others
loneliness makes you assume the worst
about others intentions towards you
because of this perceived hostile world
you can become up more self-centered to
protect yourself which can make you
appear more cold unfriendly and socially
awkward than you really are if
loneliness has become a strong presence
in your life the first thing you can do
is to try to recognize the vicious cycle
you may be trapped in
it usually goes something like this an
initial feeling of isolation leads to
feelings of tension and sadness
which makes you focus your attention
selectively on negative interactions
with others this makes your thoughts
about yourself and others more negative
which then changes your behavior you
begin to avoid social interaction which
leads to more feelings of isolation this
cycle becomes more severe and harder to
escape each time loneliness makes you
sit far away from others in class not
answer the phone when friends call
decline invitations until the
invitations stop each and every one of
us has a story about ourselves and if
your story becomes that people exclude
you others pick up on that and so the
outside world can become the way you
feel about it
this is often a slow creeping process
that takes years and can end in
depression and a mental state that
prevents connections even if you yearn
for them the first thing you can do to
escape it is to accept that loneliness
is a totally normal feeling and nothing
to be ashamed of literally everybody
feels lonely at some point in their life
it's a universal human experience you
can't eliminate or ignore a feeling
until it goes away magically but you can
accept that you feel it and get rid of
its cause you can self examine what you
focus your attention on and check if you
are selectively concentrating on
negative things was this interaction
with a colleague ready negative or was
it really neutral or even positive what
was the actual content of an interaction
what did the other person say and did
they say something bad or did you add
extra meaning to their words
maybe another person was not ready
reacting negatively but just short on
time then there are your thoughts about
the world are you assuming the worst
about others intentions do you enter a
social situation and have already
decided how it will go do you assume
others don't want you around are you
trying to avoid being hurt and not
risking opening up and if so can you try
to give others the benefit of the doubt
can you just assume that they're not
against you can you risk being open and
vulnerable again and lastly your
behavior are you avoiding opportunities
to be around others are you looking for
excuses to decline invitations or are
you pushing others away preemptively to
protect yourself are you acting as if
you're getting attacked are you really
looking for new connections or have you
become complacent with your situation of
course every person and situation is
unique and different and just
introspection alone might not be enough
if you feel unable to solve your
situation by yourself please try to
reach out and get professional help it's
not a sign of weakness but of courage
however we look at loneliness as a
purely individual problem that needs
solving to create more personal
happiness or as a public health crisis
it is something that deserves more
attention humans have built a world
that's nothing short of amazing and yet
none of the shiny things we've made is
able to satisfy or substitute our
fundamental biological need for
connection most animals get what they
need from their physical surroundings we
get what we need from each other and we
need to build our artificial humor world
based on that
let's try something together let's reach
out to someone today regardless if you
feel a little bit lonely or if you want
to make someone else's day better maybe
right a friend you haven't spoken to in
a while call a family member who's
become estranged invite a work buddy for
a coffee or just go to something you're
usually too afraid to go to or too lazy
to go to like a D&D event or a sports
club everybody's different so you know
what's a good fit for you maybe nothing
will come of it and that's okay don't do
this with any expectations the goal is
just to open up a bit to exercise your
connection muscles so they can grow
stronger over time or to help others
exercise them we want to recommend two
of the books we read while researching
this video emotional first-aid bigi
which a book that addresses among other
topics how to deal with loneliness in a
way that we found helpful and actionable
and loneliness human nature and the need
for social connection by John Cacioppo
and William Patrick it's an entertaining
and scientific exploration as to why we
experience loneliness on a biological
level how it spread in society and what
science has to say about how to escape
it links for both books in the video
description
[Music]